android is one of the most popular
operating systems in the entire world
with an active user base of 2.5 billion
people many people swear by android and
would never even consider ios thanks to
android's versatility and freedom
considering this popularity and strong
fan base you would think that android's
founder is a business icon like bill
gates or steve jobs but this is not the
case
in fact there's a large group of people
who despise the founder of android andy
rubin google actually paid andy 90
million dollars to leave the company in
october of 2014 and when the details
regarding his resignation from the
company became public 20 000 google
employees participated in a walkout
protest things actually got so heated
that many shareholders filed lawsuits
against google and google would end up
settling for 310 million dollars in
2020. from google's perspective there is
no doubt that this 400 million dollars
along with the estimated 50 million they
paid to acquire android were more than
worth it but the same cannot be said
about andy given that he not only missed
out on billions of dollars by selling to
google but also lost his reputation so
here's what happened to android's
founder
taking a look back andy rubin was born
in 1963 in chappaqua new york by trade
his father was a psychologist but by the
time andy grew up his father would
embark on his own entrepreneurial
journey he opened up a marketing firm
that took pictures of the latest
electronic gadgets this gave andea
unprecedented access to newly released
or even pre-released tech and this is
what really sparked his interest in
technology
andy would end up attending the local
high school in a city called forest
greeley high school and he would
graduate in 1981
following his primary education and he
would enroll in utica college and major
in computer science
despite this background in software andy
didn't instantly pick up a coding job at
a tech firm his first job out of college
was at call size extra microscopy where
he primarily worked with robotics it
seems that early on in his career andy
didn't have larger than life ambitions
he simply wanted to work on robotics and
see the world
this job didn't last long though as andy
would soon take a vacation that would
change the trajectory of his life after
a year in geneva and he decided to take
a trip to the cayman islands in 1989
where he would run into an apple
engineer and named bill caswell bill and
andy quickly became friends thanks to
their shared interest in engineering and
bill would end up offering andy a job at
apple and he of course took the job and
would end up as a manufacturing engineer
at apple this is actually where andy
would earn the nickname of android from
his co-workers due to his obsession with
robotics but it wasn't all sunshine and
rainbows apple as a whole wasn't doing
all that well during this time period
steve jobs had been fired years before
this and apple was slowly bleeding out
so in 1992 and he switched over to a
spin-off of apple called the general
magic that seemed to have much better
potential
most of us have probably never heard of
general magic given that the company
shut down 20 years ago but within the
tech world general magic is often
credited as being the most important
dead company in silicon valley they
worked on several groundbreaking
technologies including smartphones
mobile operating systems e-commerce
social media and even emojis there's
even a full-on documentary on general
magic if you're interested but while
they had game changing ideas these
visions never turned into tangible
success and andy would switch to web tv
in 1995 and become a communications
engineer web tv focused on making the
internet accessible through tvs and
would be acquired by microsoft for 425
million dollars in 1997 and it turned
into msn tv
and we stuck around for a few years
after the acquisition but in 1999 he
would decide that he was done with
jumping from one tech company to another
he wanted to work on something much
larger so in 1999 he would quit his job
at microsoft and found his first company
andy's first company wasn't android but
actually a company called dangerink andy
co-founded this company with two of his
friends including joe britt and matt
herschensen the company focused on
creating software and services for
mobile devices and one of their first
major partnerships was with t-mobile if
you were born in the early 1990s i'm
sure you remember the t-mobile sidekick
it was that phone that you could slide
open and type on using a full keyboard
danger was actually the company that
wrote all the software for this device
and they also played a significant role
in the design of the phone as well the
default search engine on these devices
was google.com and this would catch the
attention of larry page
larry and andy would end up meeting in
2002 at a stanford event and this would
be the beginning of a decade-long
relationship danger would go on to
release several iterations of the
sidekick but andy wanted to focus on the
software side of danger so in 2003 he
started a side project called android
with a few others the original goal of
their project was to create an open
source operating system for digital
cameras but they quickly switched over
to cell phones android was initially
just a side project that andy worked on
during the winter but in 2004 he would
leave danger and go all in on android by
this point larry had known andy for a
few years and could easily see the
potential of android so very early on in
the project larry offered to acquire
android it was never revealed how much
exactly google paid for android but
given the total amount google spent on
acquisitions in 2005 it's estimated that
they only paid 50 million dollars this
is quite ironic given that microsoft
would end up acquiring danger for 10
times that amount just a few years later
it's not clear if andy held on to a
stake in danger or not but sticking a
danger would have definitely been the
better financial move in the short term
in the long term though there's no doubt
that switching to android was the right
move
once android was acquired by google andy
no longer had to worry about funding
issues or stability as google could
easily support the operation so he
focused on trying to create an operating
system for a phone with a physical
keyboard but once the iphone launched in
2007 it was clear that android had to
target the smartphone market the problem
though was that they weren't the only
large players with such ambitions htc
motorola samsung sprint t-mobile
qualcomm and ti all wanted to create
their own open source operating system
for smartphones but android had a
multi-year development lead on all the
competition and with the samsung galaxy
and the google nexus embracing android
in 2010 there was little doubt that
google had probably won the mobile os
race and andy rubin quickly became one
of the most important executives at
google
things were looking phenomenal for andy
he had more than proved his worth and
the android has since become known as
google's best acquisition of all time
personally i'd have to disagree with
this statement as i think youtube is
google's best acquisition but there's no
question that android is definitely
within the top three despite all this
positive momentum in october of 2014
google would drop a bombshell they
announced that andy rubin would be
leaving google altogether to start up
his own hardware company this was
completely unexpected not only to detect
world but even to most of andy's
co-workers within google none of them
had expected andy to leave google so
abruptly given that he seemed pretty
content with his role there speculation
surrounding andy's departure became
rampant did andy get bored with android
did andy and larry have a conflict did
andy not like the direction in which
google was taking android and so on and
so forth despite all these questions
both andy and google remained pretty
quiet about the situation and after a
few months the media moved on to the
next piece of drama within the tech
world it wasn't until four years later
that the new york times uncovered what
truly unfolded according to the new york
times google had received a complaint
from at least one google employee that
andy was involved in misconduct and
harassment google apparently
investigated the allegations and
determined that they were in fact
credible it was clear to google's
executives that they could no longer
associate themselves with andy but at
the same time andy had played such an
influential role at the company that
they didn't just want to hire him so
they basically told andy hey andy we
know what you did we're not gonna
escalate this to the authorities or oust
you publicly but we also can't have you
stay here so just take this 90 million
dollars and leave andy of course denies
all of this and claims as departure from
google was 100 amicable and technically
these allegations were never confirmed
in court so there is no verdict on
andy's guilt nonetheless when the news
broke people around the world and
especially google employees were livid
many felt that google should have fired
andy on the spot and reported him to the
authorities instead of sending him off
with 90 million dollars and tens of
thousands of these guys would stage a
walkout protest against google in late
2018. as we touched on at the beginning
of the video these protests would
escalate into lawsuits against google
that would stretch out for years google
would apologize for the mishandling of
past cases and they confirmed that no
future employee that is like core for
misconduct allegations would be eligible
for a severance package they also agreed
to invest 310 million dollars into new
diversity equality and inclusion
measures that would prevent such
situations from reoccurring and with
that google had completely washed their
hands of andy rubin but randy it wasn't
nearly that easy
after leaving google andy co-founded a
venture capital firm called the
playground capital thanks to all of the
team's connections within the tech world
in 2015 they were able to raise 300
million dollars in venture capital from
investors including google hp foxconn
and tencent they turned around and
invested this money into a bunch of tech
startups with the most popular one being
outlapps andy focused on playground
global for a few years but soon enough
he returned to his routes and founded a
smartphone startup called essential
products the company never blew up like
android or danger but it did enjoy a
decent level of success however this
would basically evaporate overnight once
the allegations about andy came out the
company hung on for a few more years but
eventually they shut down in early 2020.
andy also left playground global around
the same time in late 2019. you would
think that with all these allegations
and negative press andy would play it
safe and stay out of the spotlight but
in 2019 he would make headline news
again
this time he didn't necessarily do
anything illegal but he did do something
that was arguably immoral apparently
andy made his wife sign a prenup two
weeks before she gave birth she has
since filed a lawsuit against andea
accusing him of coercing and
fraudulently inducing her to sign the
prenup but this case hasn't really gone
anywhere since then andy has basically
disassociated himself from all the
ventures he was involved in and has gone
dead silent
i guess it doesn't really matter for him
and given that he's worth 350 million
dollars but his current situation is
truly quite a shame andy rubin has ended
up as the man who has everything and
nothing do you guys prefer ios or
android comment that down below
also drop a like if you respect android
even if you prefer ios and of course
consider checking out our international
channels to watch our videos in other
languages and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm ari and i'll see you
guys on the next one